or jacques séguéla te voilà devenu star
aux log mes patins
alors maintenant c'est toi qui décide
qui est star qui n'est pas star a
d'ailleurs fait pas à chaque fois par
chaque émission porter le chapeau de
l'hôtel les stars n'ont sauf que le mot
star est utilisée finalement pour tout
est pourri arrête ou envie que tout le
monde des stars ce qui devrait
d'ailleurs la couture à l'américain
l'abri car un seul mot chez nous on
arrête vedette célébrités il a fait d'un
cursus ouais alors moi j'ai été à vis
des grades
on retrouve dans les armées de la gloire
voilà qui n'engage que moi bon à tepito
social a quand même un ancien club art
et morin ont qu à bien se tenir
non je crois que dans publicitaire il ya
public et moi je voudrais être un
animateur de sociétés comme il ya des
animateurs de télévision ce qui est plus
nouveau alors je sais pas si c'est à
l'aide d'études que tu là que tu l'as
trouvé enfin ce qui est ce qui est plus
nouveau en tous les cas c'est qu'on
assiste à la naissance en ce moment d'un
nouveau séguéla qui nous dit on a assez
rigolé maintenant faut retourner au sens
fort retourner aux vraies valeurs
alors qu'il ya quelques années tu me
disait la pub peut changer le monde je
dirais oui mais ça m'avait beaucoup
choqué quand elle a disparu et accule
page pour toutes ces raisons
j'étais choquée je ne suis quand même
aperçu avec l'âge que la mégalomanie
n'était tolérable lorsqu'elle avait 20
ans arrive un moment où quand même je
sais que c'est dur d'accueillir était
d'assumer son âge adulte
ouais il faut remettre un peu les
plantations d'ailleurs où est-ce qu'on
viendrait insectes a tout fait pour être
star et maintenant tu vraiment stark dit
je ne suis pas une denrée de préseau
nettement attaqué ce que tu dis mais
j'avais finalement moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ma femme mes enfants
je suis pas née maria cuba
j'ai été mégalomane devait de la plus
heureusement pas de moi grâce à toi là
n'ont engagé aucune grosse foule est pas
du tout mais je crois surtout qu'on est
en train de se tromper de stars que
c'est ridicule de dire que l'artiste on
est star de télévision avaient laissé
les wampas tard comme dirait notre ami
pivot la semaine dernière
je crois que il faut remettre les
pendules de la starisation à l'heure et
qu'il faut réserver ce titre aux gens
qui nous font vraiment rêver
en fait ce qui différencie pour moi une
star d'une vedette c'est la part du
reste a quand même passé de longues
années de ta vie et starifié les tapis
les afflelou et puis maintenant tu dis
bah c'est tarifs sont les écrivains
c'est emmerdant quand on business
peut-être ils ont peut-être le faire
mais j'ai eu bernard tapie ce matin au
quai du wault n'y avait pas encore lu le
livre the gardian corrige encore une
semaine de répit mais je crois que comme
toujours on est allé trop loin
ouais bah la rondelle on découvre des
brèches d'une mine d'or et puis on se
jette là dessus et croit qu'il faut
s'arrêter avant alors que la mini matin
moi je vais dire de choisir que
maintenant tu fais mon mea culpa c'est
très bien parce que je t'avais dis moi
quel point j'avais été choqué par la pub
changement etc
c'est à dire que pendant dix ans tu nous
as dit un truc et que maintenant ce
n'est pas suffisant a pu dire le
contraire
écoute valérie disais je ne suis pas
toujours bon avis ouais moi de retrouver
pareille d'obèses est alors maintenant
tu as fait fortune tu es riche c'est
bien parce que tu as fait porter mieux
commencé quand son corps est encore une
idée reçue via nos rangs c'est glam de
hours en argumentant que cette boîte ma
boîte et rivest leur mieux pour toi à
moi je suis je vois ma boîte mais je
veux pas d'abord oui d'accord
intéresserait pas moi je la vendrai
auras tu as fait fortune
tu as fait des enfants et maintenant ce
que ces faits puis 10 bat maintenant il
faut passer des années fric aux années
coeur mais les pauvres mecs qu'on pas
encore fait fortune et qu'on peut encore
fait d'enfants qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
penser tout ça mais je crois que pour
vivre heureux il est évidemment qu'il
faut respecter le conflit qu'il faut
respecter les patrons qui remettent
l'économie
en route et qu'il faut que demain on
gagnera tous plus d'argent mais on peut
le faire avec le coeur aux lèvres et pas
avec un billet vert entre les dents on
dit couramment et pisteurs le dit très
bien que c'est pas toi qu'a fait la pub
de mitterrand c'est mitterrand café la
tienne ce n'est pas complètement faux
day mais c'est moi qui ai dit ça qui m'a
volé je dis ce n'est pas vrai mitterrand
s'est passé que la caf et dire
mitterrand et mi-temps qui a fait dire
c'est tout à fait ça c est l argent mais
avec toutes ses affaires
qu'est-ce que tu ferais pour ton client
mitterrand pour le sortir de cette image
lui qu'à un souverain mépris de l'argent
et qui se trouve pris quand même dans
deux trois scandales faut bien le dire
comment qu'est ce que tu fais pour lui
aujourd'hui oui qu'est-ce que je lui
conseillerais oui je crois pas du tout
que ils soient pris dans quelques
scandales que ce soit lui c'est lui et
les autres sont plus d'accord quand tu
arrêtes de dire sa joie ce qu'il va dire
c'est bien le croire je prends ensuite
que
c'est un mal français que de vouloir
toujours accélérer la rumeur et que la
rumeur soit dirigé vers le pouvoir
ouvert le contre-pouvoir tout le monde
sait que c'est pas le triple du
président que de taper dans la caisse
voilà voilà voilà là vont naturellement
des passants et autres de se cacher
ouais c'est lui là donc je ne me fais
pas de souci pour lui il n'a pas besoin
de moi pour le sont dans un mauvais la
formule est pas mal dernière question si
c'était à refaire
oui pourquoi jacques séguéla si c'était
à refaire est-ce que tu serais
journaliste homme de télévision
publicitaires j'adorerais être écrivain
et là je me rends compte que c'est
vraiment dur vraiment du rien n'est plus
difficile que d'être seul là-dedans sans
taches blanches connaissait pas aussi en
sachant qu'en plus quoi que tu écrives
durera que quelques milliers de lecteurs
quand il ya cent mille électeurs ça
écrit et la twa tous les soirs quand à
plusieurs millions tu vois titre gardent
quand elle assurée sur les chaînes mais
je crois que on ne réfléchit vraiment
que par écrit et qu'après tout ça c'est
un pelage qui me fait dire ça la seule
chose qui reste nouveau tout son
équipage blanche